[Music]
when you think cringe the office or curb
your enthusiasm likely spring to mind
not star wars but a moment in andor has
viewers second-hand embarrassment alarms
going wild spoilers for the first three
episodes of and or ahead andor is a
completely different beast from the
other star wars shows to come to disney
plus unlike the other series thus far
andor aims for a grittier more street
level and more solemn look at the star
wars universe much in the same way as
the movie rogue one this isn't exactly
surprising given that andor serves as a
prequel to that film focusing on the
title character cassian andor as any
true star wars fan knows cassian ends up
dying at the end of rogue one along with
all the other main characters after
they've successfully stolen the plans
for the death star given the darker tone
of the film that inspired it and the
return of rogue one co-writer tony
gilroy as the developer of andor it's
really no wonder that the new series
leans into a narrative heaviness that
hasn't been quite as prevalent in
previous disney plus series however
despite that seriousness the show also
might feature one of the most cringe
inducing scenes in the entire star wars
universe in its second episode of course
it's not like cringe is new to star wars
but this one is on purpose meant to make
everyone in the audience feel some
second-hand embarrassment it's a
revealing moment for one of the main
players in this particular saga but that
doesn't make it any easier to watch
deputy inspector cyril khan is dead set
on finding cassian andor and bringing
him to justice for killing two guards on
the planet morlana one eventually he
gathers a squad of prelocks morlana
corporate authority officers to track
down andor he's encouraged to give a
speech to the troops to rally them but
his attempt doesn't exactly go well
there's no room for doubt on the path to
success
there are a few reasons why the writers
likely decided to go in this direction
with cyril and include such a painfully
embarrassing scene in the next episode
cassian and lutheran rail managed to
outmaneuver cyril and his soldiers in a
show of battle superiority so perhaps
it's meant to illustrate his lack of
experience there is perhaps an even
deeper meaning behind the scene that
ties in with cyril's ambitions and how
they're at odds with his actual
abilities in an interview with total
film kyle sawler who plays cyril
revealed quite a bit about his character
he said he has an extreme sense of need
to impress and fill a hole in himself
and so that really is about ascending to
the top of whatever field he's in the
field he's chosen is one of restriction
and complete control and one of
domination exactly what that
metaphorical hole that he's trying to
fill really is will likely become more
clear as andor progresses but with the
added context of sauler's interview and
what fans have seen of him throughout
the first three episodes his disastrous
speech reveals quite a bit obviously he
wants to impress his soldiers but lacks
the experience proper words or charm or
battle prowess to do so best of luck to
us all
this also makes him a nice foil for
cassian who is more personable and
relatable in his interactions with the
other characters so while cyril's speech
may be a hard scene to watch and
arguably a top cringe moment in all of
star wars it's also pivotal in showing
viewers who cyril really is
[Music]
you